you
hello and welcome to the first in a
special series of youtube q and A's with
Nobel laureates brought to you by Nobel
Prize org and NASA my name is dr. John
Mather senior astrophysicist and project
scientist for the james webb space
telescope at the nasa goddard space
flight center in greenbelt maryland i
received the 2006 Nobel Prize for
Physics along with dr. George Smoot for
building the cosmic background Explorer
satellite Kobe which detected evidence
for the Big Bang my work helped to
answer fundamental questions about how
the universe was created but now we're
offering you the chance to ask me
questions on YouTube this is a great
opportunity for you to ask about the
mysteries of space how the universe was
created and how it's growing whatever
your question the process is easy all
you have to do is record and upload your
question to YouTube before the deadline
I'll answer a selection of your
questions and my answers will be posted
on YouTube for everyone to see so upload
your questions now and I'll do my best
to answer as many of them as I can